so we've got this infinite series here
and let's see it looks like a geometric
series when you go from this first term
to the second term we are multiplying by
negative 3 and then to go to the next
term we're going to multiply by negative
3 again so it looks like we have a
common ratio of negative 3 so we could
actually rewrite this series as being
equal to negative 0.5 I could say times
negative 3 to the 0 power negative 3 to
the 0 power plus plus negative 0 or
maybe I could just keep writing this way
minus 0.5 times negative 3 to the first
power times negative 3 to the first
power minus 0.5 minus 0.5 times negative
3 to the second power and they get a 3
to the second power and we're just going
to keep going like that and we could
just say we're just going to keep having
minus 0.5 times negative 3 to eat or to
higher and higher and higher powers or
we could write this in Sigma notation
this is equal to the same thing as the
sum from let's say N equals 0 to
infinity we're just going to keep going
on and on forever and it's going to be
this first it's going to be you could
kind of think the thing we're
multiplying by negative 3 to some power
so it's going to be negative 0.5
actually must do that yellow color so
it's going to be negative 0.5 times
negative 3 negative blue color so times
negative 3 to the nth power here this is
what n is 0 here is n is 1 here is n is
equal to 2 so we've been able to rewrite
this in different ways but let's
actually see if we can evaluate this and
so we have a common ratio of negative 3
so our R here is negative 3 and the
first thing that you should think about
is well in order for this to converge
our common ratio the the magnitude of
the common ratio or the absolute value
the common ratio needs to be less than
one for convergence convergence and what
is the absolute value of negative three
well the absolute value of negative
three is equal to three which is
definitely not less than one so this
thing will not converge this thing will
not converge and even if you look at
this it makes sense because the
magnitudes of each of these terms are
getting larger and larger and larger
we're flipping between adding and
subtracting but we're adding and
subtracting larger and larger and larger
and larger and larger values intuitively
when things converge you're kind of that
the each successive term is get it tends
to get diminishing ly small or maybe it
cancels out in some type of an
interesting way
but because the absolute value of the of
the common ratio is is greater than or
equal to one in this situation this is
not going to converge to a value